welcome to two Comics two cigars the
show The New York Times one's called not
big enough to write about big news today
Robert Kelly has his new special out
killbox directed and produced by Louis
CK it's available right now for purchase
at Robert kellylive.com and Louis ck.com
guys you want to go out and get it if
you don't know Bobby you're missing out
it's one of the best comics in the world
and this new special is five years in
the making so you know it's going to be
good he's also the founder of a popular
web series called two Comics two cigars
go out and get it for real Bobby's one
of the best in the country he made this
special and uh
get it enjoy it play for your family
play for your friends if you want to get
cigar for next week it's the your next
episode it's a Cuban punch double Corona
go out find one get ready to smoke that
with us on the next episode two common
two cigars but first Me and Bobby Kelly
from the foundation Farm in Connecticut
the Tabernacle
got this special it's so [ __ ] good
all right let's start the episode
one comic is better than the other
people think it's them
we're smoking and joking and having a
blast two Comics two cigars two Comics
two cigars
should we start it we should start this
before I mean the weather is changing
like rapidly it was rainy a second ago
and now it's boiling sweat boiling sweat
and I believe there's rain clouds coming
there's wrinkle yeah welcome everybody
to
two Comics two Comics two cigars gray
skies are gonna clear up I don't think
so bring out your nasty dead we are here
I mean this is an epic episode of two
Comics two cigars and I mean look it
it's two Comics two two cigars we have
the same cigar
we review it we talk about at the
beginning in the middle at the end yeah
and then we tell you none one five or a
box don't forget to look at the bottom
of the video and we'll tell you what
cigar we're smoking next time it's every
couple weeks or so and we'll tell you
what cigar so you can go out and get
them but today is one that you can't
really get yeah I was sorry about that
we're sorry about that we can we find
someone close you can get but we're here
okay yeah let's do it the rogans we're
smoking the rogans today not only are we
smoking the rogans we're here with the
rogans
are made are made at the Tabernacle no
what is this called oh my God I mean the
foundation Foundation but I'm saying
what did you call this Farm we're at the
farm we're at the farm thank you I'm
gonna be sweating a lot
we're at the farm we're in the tobacco
Fields this is an epic cigar episode I
don't think any any cigar uh podcast has
ever done this no Nick from Foundation
took us around these [ __ ] interesting
really cool let's start smoking let's
start smoking we're gonna start smoking
all right so we'll talk about this we're
smoking these you can't get these when
you go on Joe Rogan Experience Podcast
he'll generally hand you
uh Blended by Foundation cigars yes
cigar but if you do want to try the
cigar they're based on this cigar right
here the Tabernacle the Tabernacle which
is still hard to find very hard to get
you probably won't get these either yeah
the rogans themselves you can only get
um if you're Rogan yeah or if you've
been recently canceled uh you'll be able
to get on there and [ __ ] it here you
want to do this yeah sure I'll cut your
cigars and I'll cut mine
um the way you want to cut it just let
everybody know a little information yeah
I I would like to know this okay there's
this is there's caps if you see the last
I see two caps there's two caps
sometimes there's a Triple cap this is a
double cap I believe the top cap you
want to cut it make like a little eye
and just get that top cap off Gish
excuse top cap you make that noise if
you want you can make any noise you want
I like douche that's not bad I'll do it
like a like a female tennis player okay
huh
that was pretty spot up thanks thanks
remember they got mad at Steffi Graf
because she was like uh moaning yeah and
the other opponent's like hey can you
shut the [ __ ] up already like it's very
annoying it was it was very like you're
distracting me hey
it actually was kind of hot it was very
hot yeah it sounded like she was getting
it brought a lot of men into the sport
it did it sounded like she was getting
her taint tickled
oh you're not even lighting the cigar
right
I mean he I mean we just no that's not
it either I'm just Browning it toasting
toasting it not Browning that's
offensive
toasting
toasting
okay that's a toast
yeah hold the cigar out like that don't
let the blue Fame hit you just want to
toast the end see that this is actually
good information it's not it's not
touching the flame isn't touching it I'm
just toasting the end and I'm but I'm
not I'm letting that suck a light up get
red hot I'm not doing it for a second
I'm just letting that see how that's
toasting I mean you don't get any of the
edges doesn't come down at all edges I'm
just toasting that cigar getting it red
all over and then
so I go back
or children now that's perfectly lit
look at that okay let me try it okay
what's new Bob
I don't know what's new I think my
physique oh yeah since the last time
Bobby's on this podcast he's down 50
[ __ ] pounds 50 pounds baby
50 pounds
it's gonna be funny if you go back and
see the first episode of two Comics
Deuces guys I was massive
yeah I was on the verge of uh stroke
but now I feel fantastic
people were worried about you they're
like [ __ ] and like Bobby looks terrible
like he actually doesn't look like that
anymore I was recorded about three
months ago but
the Magic The Magic of [ __ ] TV
were they really was that with the
comments Bobby's gonna die
that's good that's good that's good okay
just a little bit you don't want to nail
the the butane yeah but I'm feeling good
man I um well right off the bat though
can I just talk about let's talk about
the cigar you've had the cigar okay
honestly let's talk about the history of
why we're even here and everything like
that forget so I had you're my cigar uh
Sensei Sensei yes
um cigar say
and I went on Rogan's podcast and I
smoked a few and Rogan smoked I think
not quite as much as me back then and um
and he's like I had these cigars and The
Joe Rogan brand cigars now the
experience I have with a with a name
brand of anything else is weed and
somebody's like hey they put uh you know
Tommy Chong's name on a week and it's
like this is usually novelty things
right and I was like sure I'll try your
[ __ ] I expected a swisher sweet
and I smoked and I was like actually
this is really good and I told you about
it yeah and you were like
um oh do you know the history of that I
was like no I just thought do I have bad
taste like no you have good taste you
have good taste because Connecticut I
knew about uh Foundry cigars I knew
about them because I was interested in
them because they're in Connecticut
Connecticut
has been doing tobacco for years
Connecticut was there's two things you
can get in Connecticut three things
three things you can get tobacco
the best pizza on the world in New Haven
New Haven Connecticut and hats back in
the day Danbury Connecticut hat City
look it up that's only no no let's put
that down but there's a fourth thing no
no what's the fourth thing old style
racism oh yeah New England style races
in the UK I really get across the
country anymore yeah the harmful racism
we're like uh nah no no no no benches on
our bus stops
that's still this still exists yeah the
maids can stand we don't want blacks
coming in
um yes but I do
dude I love breaking out my Spanish the
whole [ __ ] field they annoyed me we
walked up into one of the barns yeah
because you guys use the plural oh like
but I was just like this
messes shut the [ __ ] up how's that
that's from Boston
yeah you really walked up and just
started winging it up you were so
excited so excited you see a brown guy
in a field I guarantee you this guy
speaks Spanish
ain't no mistake gonna be made here
so anyways you told me about you told me
that you smoked this guy I knew all
about Nick I knew about you know that
he's growing tobacco here again he's
making cigars again and Foundation
cigars I smoked a foundation I really
enjoyed it I was actually following him
on Instagram before already yes so when
you told me that and then you actually
had a box of them yeah so I got a box of
my ass Rogan I was like hey those are
good do you know the the name of it the
not the Joe Rogan's you know
um but the name of it because I'd like
to buy some yeah doing okay you know I
have a box of cigar money yeah
um it's interesting I took a Bridget
Conquest he'll be on the podcast at some
point to smoke his first cigar we're in
Buffalo and go smoke a cigar has never
smoked one I smoked one I asked the guys
like let me get one that doesn't make
you nauseous This Guy's new time he goes
flavored I'm like no not flavored I can
see he's black because he's black but a
lot of black guys like the acid but
we're not doing the flavors cherry and
um and he got a cigar and we're smoking
it in a cigar lounge and it was nice he
goes how much was a cigar it was like
twelve dollars he goes I thought this
was for Kings I didn't know this is an
accessible 12 bucks two beers I'm like
yeah man it's two beers there's two
beers it'll last you a lot longer cigars
premium cigars
and our
are so attainable right now for the
average [ __ ] if you know what you're
smoking I mean this cigar is not that
expensive you can't get this one but how
much is okay so now this is the the
closest version of it that you can get
in the store and again he told us nick
uh from Foundation told us he goes these
are and Jeffrey told us these are hard
to find the Tabernacle you won't be able
to get any of this stuff for smoke yeah
we were gonna smoke they do have other
cigars they have other cigars Foundation
cigars are beautiful cigars uh I I like
I found in a cigar shop in uh I went
looking in Austin for the for the Rogan
the other one and I did find actually
the Tabernacle but I was like I'm not
sure that's that or not I thought that
David and Goliath there's two one with a
a Cuban uh leaf and one with a Havana
spicy whatever smoked agent reached out
to
um to the company to Nick and I was like
what's the difference he told me I was
like it's just interesting it's
interesting making them all cigar people
of friendly man they love when you when
you appreciate their cigar because
there's so much that goes into this you
know like if you look at these fields I
mean this is nuts you won't see this
tobacco in a cigar for how long three
three four years it's crazy
right yeah I mean anything else they
make you eat it tomorrow yeah smoke it
tomorrow no so it's kind of like a
scotch right it's exactly like wine and
people don't understand that it's not a
cigarette it's not a vape it's not a
swisher sweet it takes a a master
blender it takes different types of
tobacco and it takes years
years of fermentation
you know from from from growing it to
picking it to to put it hanging in a
barn sending it sending it out that was
cool to hang it all in a barn to dry out
was a very cool thing that was amazing
yeah it's a cool tour but um yeah so you
told me I told you that I knew I gave
you the history about you know tobacco
in Connecticut yeah the the soil here he
explained to us which is real
interesting it used to be a finger Lake
a Long Long Lake it used to be a finger
Lake probably from the Great Lakes all
the way from Canada
all the way down here to Connecticut and
then it opened up into the Long Island
Sound and became the Connecticut River
Lake push through so this was all lake
bed this is all lake so Eagles you have
and this is what all farmers do I love
it I want to do this this is what
farmers do he goes you'll have soil Hill
it's real silty and it's almost like
it's almost like the bottom of a lake
yeah you're about to do an accident no
I'm gonna do an actor this is what
farmers do they go
yeah
got to taste it oh yeah I'm gonna
tasting mud [ __ ] off I thought you'd do
it
um yeah so this was all so the sand yeah
and this is the bottom of a river yeah
so this the the the plants can grow here
the only part that sucks is that like
unlike Nicaragua or Cuba there's the
seasons there's Seasons at some point
yeah
um I learned a lot I learned about
Ecuador because I was like how come
those Ecuadorian cigars and he's like
you're way wrong there's tons of [ __ ]
people things grow out their cigarettes
like you're saying there's no name brand
cigars from Ecuador and I was like now
that one that one you oh God [ __ ] boo
Fair it's all I had to smoke I got used
to it you ever get used to something
shitty in your life but you're like
married for 15 years
apology
just leave it out there
I want to do it for podcasts I want to
be like I'll call a a section called um
uh out of context just take out the
contest and leave one horrible thing
yeah black people yeah I don't want a
black one it's just like I just take out
there we're talking about jelly beans
yeah this right off the bat though this
is spicy you can taste it on the back of
my tongue this is a um let's call it a
man cigar do you taste it yeah you taste
the spice on the sides up in the back on
the sides not as much as you taste it
take a little bit take a little bit in
leave it in your mouth
right yeah I do actually
yeah it's a little spicy a little spicy
spicy and and cigars are great because
you know it does mellow out a little bit
as you start to smoke it it Mellows out
so right off the top you're getting a
little you're getting that your tongue's
going a little nuts that's what I
noticed about that that Ecuadorian cigar
yeah that you wait the second half is a
different taste in the first half yeah
the first half is garbage the second
half is [ __ ] but in general in a cigar I
didn't make the I didn't even make the
middle of that today you you're like
three like I'm I'm gonna just wasting it
we're gonna have to do an episode an
extra like uh of that cigar again this
cigar again no the [ __ ] one yeah we'll
do one we'll have to try that again I'll
move on you one of your [ __ ] Ecuador
treats yeah treats so so anyway so I
asked Rogue I was like uh tell me what
cigar goes dude we're buddies I'll send
you a box sweet two months goes by give
me your address it's fine here two
months goes by no subscribe I'm like
dude I want to bother you just tell me
the [ __ ] name of the [ __ ] thing I
don't want you to send it to me just
tell me the name of it because now give
me the address again I'll send it to you
send me a box
um well listen no he gave me a box in
Austin I drove to Houston for skank Fest
I had my own box of rogans that's right
and I was like check it out I got a box
you want one
let's do a reenactment of what how you
took one
Bobby check it out I got these box of
[ __ ] rogans oh my God those look so
nice yeah you can't get these yeah
what no oh what
are you [ __ ] grubbied it if he was
Jewish I would understood the Holocaust
that's how [ __ ] grubby you got but
it's fine you can't get them you can't
get them you can't you literally can't
get them you can't get them and you had
them and I had plenty you're gonna enjoy
them God damn right I did that reminds
me of Joe List's wedding when you bought
a box of uh my father's the judges how
about two two and then Joe is so mad
because you see him smoked about that
much and just left out he's like what
the [ __ ] he was so angry I'm like but
Joe they're for everyone to try one
during your wedding they're not for
bringing home well the thing with cigars
listen you have to you have to it's like
um
it's like pizza well you have a group of
people like when I did uh JFL I had the
they have the big Just for Laughs they
have the big party in the round bar
right I started another party out in the
lobby a pizza party
right so and you're drinking me they
just we ordered like 10 pizzas for the
lobby we knew that we were just gonna
get everybody who's cool was going to
come out and have a slice of pizza but
yeah so we ordered pepperoni sausage all
the good stuff right cheese but I said
we have to order a decoy Pizza a decoy
decoy Pizza
it's a vegetable pizza for the people
you don't like the people you don't know
the people that don't hey can I have
pizza yeah right over there yeah the
asparagus right over there it's getting
rid of them cigar is the same thing
every real cigar guy has a row of cigars
the hey hey dude what's your name I've
always wanted to try a cigar could I
have one sure let me go to the second
the humidor that's for you you [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] so when we bought uh for
Norma's bachelor party we went in Tampa
it's cheap cigars everywhere and we
bought a box of the judge uh he wanted
those yeah it's a very good cigar we'll
smoke that at some point on this on this
podcast so go ahead and guys find the
judge uh my father the judge but but um
Joe was like everybody at the bachelor
party has never smoked we gotta find
some shitty ones and I'm like okay but
dude but we can't say they're shitty
ones to people we gotta say oh this is a
real oh you're new this is a smooth one
we'd say hey give them one of the smooth
ones that was our oh really like you
know what is it but I don't smoke much
it's okay dude it's a bachelor party
yeah it's worth it how much was it 45
and you don't tell them you just here
here this is your cigar no band nothing
cost a dollar fifty yeah there you go
that's for you she's like [ __ ] You Chris
Allen that's what you got
um
um yeah but this this cigar it's good
this guy's no joke like you got to be I
mean this is the funny part too he gave
us this box
sucker we have to split it
I'll take it home and I'll split it up
and then I'll bring you back the extras
I don't know if that's gonna fly
can't fly if you don't try all right
there you go
um so what tell us all the [ __ ] that he
told us about in this [ __ ] we took a
tour of the [ __ ] Fields the curing
barns we took a tour of every I mean he
he really laid a lot of info on us in a
short amount of time I mean this this is
one of the tobacco Leafs this is a
tobacco this will be the wrapper am I
right
damn it bad you just ashed all over
yourself I mean this is just a
professional
I mean this is cigar guy support cigar
people are watching this go what the
[ __ ] it's an accessible podcast
this is a cigar bar in Jersey that if
you Ash like that they ring a bell and
they get you out they all just go he
they just ring it they they point to you
dude I asked into a hot tub I was I like
the long you can get the longest uh
chair you can get it's one of my
favorite things they can get the Cherry
over half gold spoke to David off it was
like three quarters me and Segura and
Chrysler smoked one in Atlanta it just
wouldn't pop off so I was doing that in
a in a hot tub in in Western Maryland
and my friends weren't looking at me
whatever and I was just in the hot
they're about to get in and uh and then
it just fell I heard it I'm like oh [ __ ]
I try to get it all out and then I
wouldn't get out it was it was sinking
in so I just turned the Jets on Let It
mix up it was like everybody's wearing
eyeliner I even knew too I was like I
should ask this outside this isn't one
of those Cherry moments yeah I I like
letting it go for a while but I'll Ash
yeah I had one guy I remember I was at a
cigarette literally down to the bottom
and they were smoking like this yeah
it's unenjoyable but you have to do it
for the record I don't agree I you look
like an idiot yeah you do and you're not
enjoying your cigar I get what you're
trying to do yeah but you look like a
[ __ ] it's also like dude wants to see
how good the cigar is you don't do it
every time you smoke it yeah
um so what is I thought they wrapped it
in this they rolled it in this they cut
it in half they said they take out the
middle they take this is the stem the
main vein yeah what they do is they take
this out they went from the top down
yeah they go from here down they take it
out up here
and they pull this whole main vein out
yeah they could go like this right yeah
and you pull it like this like that I'm
gonna do it yeah all right there you go
and then you pull this sucker out like
this yeah like that
and this look at this oh all right pull
the main vein out like that
I [ __ ] up Marissa when I said when he
said I was wrong cut that out too please
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right here you go put this main vein
out like this yeah right
right down the middle where I like that
throw that [ __ ] out and this right in
here yeah right and you can see how the
oils and share we'll get we'll get
Glamor Shots of those yeah as well
they'll make the cigar they'll cut in
here and that's what they use to make
the cigar as the wrapper as a rapper I
don't know what this one is yeah look
how Brown that is and it's so silky and
there's so much oil in it like you can
see we'll show you this it does not
smell like a cigar yet oh no well the
thing is this has to ferment so these
will go in Plants I didn't know
fermented they ferment there's a barn
over here but it smells like sheep [ __ ]
like if you go in there it's all ammonia
it smells like ammonia you you'll pass
out
and they have to let it sit [ __ ] it's
like my kind of place yeah it does
that's good [ __ ] redneck drugs it's
like often uh tough and exhaust pipes I
think in certain States I think
Pennsylvania you can't buy uh you can't
buy whipped cream unless you're 21.
it's fine too because people want
whipping the most are children well one
of the last
hot I've ever had was off that whippets
not whippets you want to hear the story
I mean you want the short version or the
long version long version
you're a long cigar when I was I was in
um
upstate New York
near outside of Rochester the people
around New York is a state in the United
States of Cal of of America yeah and
that's when they say the states this is
one of the states go ahead
should make sure everyone's on the same
page go ahead
over explaining
um what was it what town was it um
Spencerport New York
I lived there I so I was in that igl all
that I was around 15. my parents moved
up there while I was in jail
and then into a fast home they moved up
there so I got shipped up there okay
from a foster home and I'm
the [ __ ] was that
I don't know you think it was your
camera like for the truck I might have
been the truck I'm gonna check the
camera but you keep talking all right
it was a truck
still recording shut that door
so
you all right yep so I'm up there and
you know at this point I was drinking so
much that I really it took me a lot to
get drunk nice I mean I had a half a
bottle of white label scotch I had a
bunch of beers and I was still not
[ __ ] up regular shingles over here so
yeah I was 15.
um so we went into the grocery store to
get whippets
and the screw top kind though you know
just a whipped cream sandwich you know
and we went in we [ __ ] did like three
we got high as we're leaving
the two kids were [ __ ] around the
gumball machines
and they're like they're trying to they
wanted the gumball machine
so
I was like get the [ __ ] out of the way I
grabbed the gumball machine I snapped it
off we took it outside
we got all the [ __ ] degenerate
children a nickel one and a quarter one
wow and we took all the change we filled
up Pockets with change and gumballs you
guys got to understand back in that day
it was a long time ago quarters were
worth like 36 37 cents it's not like the
quarter today I think you're gonna say
37
so yeah I mean and then we we the cops
were called
as they should have been running down
the tracks
[ __ ] wasted you know on whippets and
[ __ ] in white labeled Scotch yeah I
hopped a fence
and there was a shotgun in my face
cop I heard he actually he he cranked it
wow in my face he said
he said get on your knees I'm in
somebody's front yard by the way he
dragged me out to the front yard put me
on my knees he said get on your knees
get on your stomach hands behind your
head to the other copy goes if he moves
shoot him
and I looked up and I went it was gum
I would have been that would have been
like that's a move
that counts the move so they took me to
jail wow downtown Rochester or wherever
the [ __ ] it was or Spencerport and um
Rochester jails the second only to
Thailand jails it was dude let me tell
you something they took me in there
they're grilling me they're grilling me
right so your second favorite type of
girl I'm lying now I'm like I don't know
what you're talking about Go [ __ ] You
I'm from Boston never admit by the way
just in general with cops we were
speeding I saw you texting there's no
benefit in this thing it'll be easier
for you there's zero benefit to
admitting oh it's a trick it's a trick
they're gonna Rush either way
never admit never admit so I'm not
admitting I'm with the two toughest guys
up there in Spencerport pretty tough
guys
uh he goes you better tell us now I'm
giving you one more shot I go no you're
adding I don't know what you're talking
about he goes your friends are going to
rat on you they're going to tell I go no
he opens the door those two kids are
crying
in tears signing away oh no that I broke
the [ __ ] thing
I have a record they don't this is the
first time offense they're going home
damn my whole Theory went out the window
I never rushed it was so I can really
helped them out
you're not getting off like no you did
that's what the other two kids did so
I'm in I go that night they bring me
back to the scene of the crime I had to
I buried the [ __ ] change
behind the house before the shotgun it's
like one of those guys who hikes the
bank and like going to jail for 10 years
like well I'll have the money when I get
out yeah it's buried somewhere well they
made me pick him back and get the money
damn it had to be like five bucks
but I already had a record so when
you're a ward of a state yeah there's no
there's no you just go to jail right
there's no court you don't go home I was
on probation
so I go to Rochester jail which was the
scariest jail I've ever been in
yeah it was nuts dude I mean you they
threw you in a room let me sell it was
the first time I got on my knees did you
get raped did you rape there's no raping
in kids jail got raped you're only in
there for six months
you were waiting for the opportunity be
honest yes I mean it never happened I
was very disappointed are you guys
interested in uh dick sucking and uh
we'll probably be out of here soon I
still gotta work on my [ __ ] college
applications for that [ __ ] Jello I'm
getting out tomorrow I'm good I don't
like how you could have him like I owe
you one [ __ ]
so I was in the gym I got on my that's
the first time I prayed to God yeah how
you don't like that do you no yeah well
it worked if I was God in that moment
I'd be like well well well
look who needs me now where were you
when everything was good A little bit of
thanks would have gone a long way
God you know that I I didn't see the
light now I see the light God's smoking
one of those Rogan cigars before it was
a rogue there is no time in God's life
so he's like this is always gonna be the
best cigar
this is Beautiful by the way this is a
great cigar it's [ __ ] it's a great
cigar epic I'll give this an epic right
now it's epic I mean my tongue isn't
dirty sometimes you smoke a cigar your
mouth feels yucky you gotta take a sip
of something or clean your palate this
so I mean geez
I mean we're ripping through this still
but anyways I I actually I went to jail
I was there for a week it was terrifying
I was a number
you had to get out of your cell in the
morning like real deal my people did
numbers too but it was different yeah
there were longer numbers
they're like this guy's only got four
digits you're one of the earth
no I always thought at the gift shop in
Auschwitz they should sell a long sleeve
t-shirt with a number on the sleeve you
you were correct
I was just thinking the other day I want
merch and and it's for my new special
Jew coming in October
um maybe October 26th I want maybe
shirts that says Jew and then just has
an armband like a yellow on the sleeve
yellow with this Jewish star you know it
says Juden it's [ __ ] good maybe I
don't know yeah we'll see okay
um uh my special coming out at the end
of October both of us I don't have
enough end of September oh my gosh mine
doesn't have a name though I don't have
a name for it
still breathing wow
how about thinner than when I tape this
dude people are going to lose this guy
doing promos It's gotta be weird dude
all my pictures from my I did my last
special and then I went to you know to
my Walkabout in Southeast Asia and I
came back
15 pounds lighter than I'm supposed to
be right I'm now 15 pounds above what
I'm supposed to be so 30 pounds lighter
than this so I had to do my promo shots
Netflix and stuff and it was like who's
this skinny gaunt guy that's not the guy
who taped the thing I was like camera
has 10 pounds like you're taking a
pictures on camera too was this picture
taken in 1941
at the height of Jewish weight loss
yeah I don't know her name I have a name
I got a beginning will you help me with
the name there's always a fallback live
in Tampa
if I can't do live I did live at the
village underground yeah um yeah we'll
talk over on the way back we'll talk
over the name okay well I'll let your
watch is special and then you'll come up
with the name correct I was thinking uh
remember AIDS
that's a great one yeah that's a great
title it's catchy as [ __ ] it'll catch
some pushback which will help like
promote it I know unfortunately now it's
such a weird line because you want
pushback to for promotion but you want
too much pushback because then no one
can put no good air it you want to get
to the edge of canceling yeah lucky your
special is on Louis ck.com so there is
no canceling that
well that website has survived it
survived yes there's nothing I can say
that's really people are going to be
like no if his fans push back then we're
in trouble then you're like oh maybe I
did something wrong you're definitely
wrong
um but yeah dude I don't know that's
great I'm so excited about your special
I'm excited about yours you're uh
you stand up somebody I read something
about you the other night
that you were [ __ ] so funny
they saw you do stand-ups it was on the
internet and I read this stuff sometimes
and they were like I can't believe how
[ __ ] amazing he was he's mediocre on
podcasts but on stand up it's like the
thing he actually cares about I wasn't
you that was Louis damn it that was
Louis at the cellar last night I
apologize I thought it was you I'm sorry
it was Louis
you are funny though you're a [ __ ]
I swear to God we have a comment for the
algorithm maybe say if you saw me live
or from that's unfunny than you thought
I got a whip it story what is it so I
work at the comedy so it's got David
manager
uh he used to be homeless writing
himself you know pulled himself up
that's what you can do when you're white
and uh got a job night manager at The
Comedy Store
and um anyway it's a good guy and one
day the bartender Huck
once I use the whipped cream for one of
those you know whipped creamy drinks
yeah
came out like watery it's like yeah it's
effective got another one watery again
another one water again David late night
was doing [ __ ] whippets out of the
[ __ ] easy whip ready whip yeah
getting high and it takes all the
[ __ ] the the yeah
it was great I got another story too we
had to do I did a lot of commercials and
so I was doing a commercial audition for
ready whip
right you yeah an audition and you're
supposed to be the ready whip guy and
you're like ready when you wanted to
make it oh dude I was doing so many
commercials I I probably did 75
commercials you did 75 commercials on
television yeah
well they're as cheesy as your Sam Adams
commercial no they were way better that
was
I'm sorry I'll never let this down and I
don't deserve to live it down hey man
friends that's what friendship's about
not letting you live down [ __ ] cheesy
moments fair when you were insincere for
a buck
yeah I was like I was like he gave me a
lot of money to do it you're like but
why wouldn't you have been funny though
I'm like ah [ __ ] I don't have time I
throw myself at the mercy of the court I
didn't have time we need more comedy
court so the other one was ready whip
right and so you had to like hold this
thing and you had to go ready ready Whip
and kind of like pretend to take a
little bit and jump around you're
supposed to be real like uh Jay Davis
like you know like like jumping around
and like real hyper and [ __ ] right
anyway the guy was like uh all right can
I show you something the guy running the
commercial audition I was like yeah
because he knows me that and uh he goes
look at this one guy's tape and he goes
ready he took a thing but he didn't take
it down yeah so he took it up that's
when you get all the [ __ ] head stuff
and none of the mouth stuff took it up
it was ready and then he gets high but
he's still trying to do the commercial
and he goes ready if I could fall
through the stool right and then still
tries to jump up and save it because
it's his future you know ready to put it
and then smashed into the wall and it
falls over
some of those commercials it was the
lowest level of the industry so for
every flow from [ __ ] Allstate you get
a [ __ ] could be a homeless guy
we did one and it was a guy who was like
we had to pretend to steal second base
it was like uh EA Sports or something or
maybe whatever it was we had to Pretend
We're on the street and there's the the
crossing guards going like this and as
soon as he goes like this we're gonna
steal second and slide in you know and
they're just gonna see giant into a
street but we're like and so the guy's
like I played uh high schools baseball
do you think they should I tell them
that in the waiting room was like I
don't think this matters it's it's like
just a normal guy thing you don't have
to go to this I'll tell him
because okay so then another one they
showed me is like let me show I walked
into my audition giant hole in the wall
and I was like what happened let me show
you
[ __ ] off he's stealing second and he
over slides the back it just [ __ ]
kicks a hole right in the [ __ ] wall
it did not book the commercial I had an
audition one time for the wahlbergs
wahlburger no it was for a movie okay
salty movie oh okay and I go in and it's
all it's all these salty kids all these
Dorchester Southie kids Dorchester dude
[ __ ] you I mean there I apologize I
don't mean that yeah they're no job I
don't mean that I take that back it was
a joke I do jokes on podcast I say the
opposite of what I mean back in the day
I go and these kids are [ __ ] ruthless
Boston just punks yeah and they're
making a movie and the scene is I gotta
come in and stuff Mark Wahlberg just
came from blinding a guy
I was like I tried to apologize but
McKay's blind you didn't just cut him
off in traffic he's blind forever so
dude the scene is I gotta start mouthing
off to these guys and then they start
funking me up yeah they [ __ ] me up
we're really dude they [ __ ] me up
verbally no physically they beat the
[ __ ] out of me in the audition they took
me to the ground they started kicking me
what dude
like you [ __ ] sucker you [ __ ]
who you think you're talking to the real
stomper like the [ __ ]
stomp I had a [ __ ] I had to yell like
pause I was like pause I said pause I
don't know why I said boss I'm not even
the bit I'm like pause and they finally
you all right you all right I'm like no
I'm good hey you took it that was good
and I thought at least I'll get it
because they beat the [ __ ] out of me
yeah yeah I didn't get it I had one for
Pizza Hut the zone
I went in there for the audition and
they go okay you're in a store in a mall
and some guy it's gonna be Tommy
Davidson is going to come in and um and
uh introduce the Zone all right first
one on I pretend to try I was like oh
okay cool thanks you go the second one
do it more realistic like what what
would you do if somebody did come into
your actual store you're moving boxes
and stuff
and uh so me and this other guy you know
they pair you up all the time some
random in the audience and um best
paired up me and renazisi they paired us
up randomly oh that's great to do a
Tiger Woods EA Sports we're talking [ __ ]
to each other on the level that only
friends could do right he xerox's um his
uh passport he's going out of the
country and uh I'm like oh how about
this now I just ripped up his [ __ ]
Xerox he's like I need that for after
we're just [ __ ] we both booked it anyway
so the zone so it's this guy's like hey
can you try the position it's like hey
man you can't come in try it realistic
you can't come into our store dude we're
working you can't just come in and try
to sell stuff that's not how it works
you gotta have a permit for this stuff
and the other guy's like what the [ __ ]
are you doing dude we left literally the
guy goes hey thanks for ruining it for
both of us oh really yeah that guy had
to see me on that commercial
yeah I sure did you had to be like ah
what
um when I did Law and Order one time and
I what were you I hope you were the guy
who goes who's just like the first two
minutes we're like I can't jog I can't
get in shape Tony call the cops I'm in a
tobacco field Tony call 9-1-1
I was a cop I was a cop Vincent afrio
I've done four of them Vince Vince and
Africa I'm in my scene with Vince you
might know him as Vincent D'Onofrio that
guy Vincent D'Onofrio go Vince D'Onofrio
I call him Vince
so the guy we had a dead body but you
can't you can't just make a dead body
it's too much money so you have to hire
an actor to lay still just to there's
people there's they don't breathe
they're skill is to not breathe there's
people that not to be zombies wow like
professional zombies from Walking Dead
wow there's professional then how to
walk they know how to move them up
there's professional dead people that
know how to just hold their breath and
not breathe during the scene and look
dead
so we sh we're shooting the scene we go
through the first take I look down I go
how'd you get this job
how did you get the job
he didn't laugh no he was like he was
like and he just went back to being dead
all right speed he was gonna go back to
being dead the guy hated me so bad
[ __ ] pissed at me at lunch
[ __ ]
off you're dead
it is a weird thing auditions are the
worst auditions are the worst somebody
said it though uh Harris Pete the old
door guys the story he said he goes
Hollywood's the only place where they
pay you multiple times for the same job
because the audition process sucks but
when you get it because compared to this
you're working in an office building say
hey we need to move these boxes upstairs
to the attic okay uh sure I'll do it
fine here's 30 bucks thank you for doing
it uh later two weeks later somebody
goes hey did anybody move those boxes up
to the to the to the attic and go yeah I
already did it goes all right give him
30 bucks
and then later the building gets sold
they had to move the boxes out of there
you get another 30 bucks residuals are
the best residuals are the best thing
ever because they come when you need
them
during the pandemic I I got I got a
eight thousand dollar check I made more
on the residuals than I did on the movie
I made that movie uh what was it on on
something what are the results gonna be
like for uh Fourth of July nothing
I'm not getting a die not [ __ ] let's
say Louie's Mexican but he's Jewish no
it's a low it's a low budget movie
you're a low budget friend you're a low
budget [ __ ] Jew
how's that not bad let's get back and
forth we had
um clip it
yeah
the residuals are the best but
auditioning is the worst I [ __ ] hate
it I can't I don't I don't like it
because because you need approval it's
such a it's not just like oh here's what
I do they know what they want you're
desperate they know what they want a lot
of the times and you got to come in and
really do something crazily crazy
different or the person they want has to
[ __ ] up really bad and I get the process
but they bring you in for stuff and it
just it's such an awkward thing if you
give me the job I'll do it right all the
stuff I got Louis
um it always just gives you the job
Louie just gives you the job because he
knows what you can do he knows it's so
funny because he's high level right Joe
list is low level and he goes I want I
want uh Chris Walsh to this role I think
he'd be really good for it and Louis
like okay again a music should I get him
a foundation goes no get him because
when's the audition goes did you like
him just get him Liz can't wrap his head
around the idea that you could just book
somebody can I tell you why yeah that is
yeah Louie's a great director he knows
how to get he knows how to give you the
information the direction you need
together get what he wants he knows what
he wants
so if you're a director and you don't
know what you want you're hoping the
actor will give you something get there
for you no you want it but good
directors know exactly what they want
and he'll let you do your thing and then
say that's good but don't let's try it
this way do that you know to the point
where Louis will help you
you know and some actors don't like lime
reads so don't tell me how to all I want
is a line reader I'm like at one time in
a commercial the same thing the guy's
like God do it less do it more one more
ghetto more straight whatever you wanted
and eventually I was like hey dude I'm
actually a comic about an actor I will
not be offended can you just sit in this
chair do the line the way you want me to
do it and I'll just mimic you yeah and
the guy's like really like I do I don't
care about acting I'm just good at it
but I don't have any in inside whatever
to it I agree I agree you give me a nice
hotline read so I can get it yeah and
I'm gonna make it mine yeah I'm gonna
add my [ __ ] which is great but yeah
auditioning is the [ __ ] worst dude
it's the worst it's the worst
it's just it's because it's an unnatural
thing it's auditioning for it and no
one's there you're not in the scene so
you have to pretend you're in the scene
commercial distance the worst because
you have to pretend you're bouncing a
basketball right you have to pretend
they're like oh you have a ball oh my
God you can't just get a ball for this
duck thing you want a french guy for
this I don't want me you want a guy who
can dribble a ball be tennies in a box
pull some rope I can't dribble a ball
and then remember this [ __ ] right you
know yeah I [ __ ] awful but
what are you gonna do
this is so nice dude this is so relaxing
there's actually I love summertime so
much I do too I'm so sad you can feel
it's going away I already saw leaves
starting to fall I'm like [ __ ] I gotta
find a way to do my touring this year
I'm gonna schedule it right now
ski places or Beach places so I got
Tampa and and uh another Florida place
two weeks in a row uh I got uh Salt Lake
City in the winter you know for skiing I
got Vancouver for skiing and then it's
like that's all I want my agent's like
nah come on dude you gotta stop skiing
to Columbus
stop and it makes me stop yeah but
that's the problem I'll limp you're
gonna wind up [ __ ] hurting your spine
I'll have a good life until then
all right whatever don't say I didn't
warn you
where are you going to tell me you're
pissing on the [ __ ] tobacco field
yeah are you taking a piss Yep this is
this is typical Ari this is we they
invite us here they're gonna see this
what did that someone's gonna get a
really shitty cigar in three years
that's a good point you understand that
yeah you're not supposed to piss in the
field piss him piss out here Fair
are you gonna piss out here yeah no
don't piss out here no piss over there
it's over there okay
in the field this is in the field you
got all the workers looking at your
clock now
oh it's so Blanco ah Blanco what the
[ __ ] is that white
that's the movie Blanco movie but he's
pissing right now this is fantastic
taking a hot piss now I take my band off
really do you leave your band on like
the whole time you told me once we did a
podcast for skeptic tank about about
cigars from the stoop at the seller yeah
and you told me I remember this
some people just smoke right through the
band
they don't even take it off ever some
people do
the thing about cigars is that everybody
has their own technique and real cigar
people there's no right or wrong I know
guys who just take the band off right at
the beginning they don't even want the
[ __ ] band
and I tend I tend to agree what are you
doing
now they're going to think I mean if
this watching us anybody's wife they're
gonna think I blew you like they can't
only see you doing your pants in my head
they can see the top of my head over the
tobacco plants
okay
is that new for you this is [ __ ]
brand new it's great that is how long
have you been doing this
I've been doing a long time what's up
how you doing that's great Bobby
congratulations thank you buddy
can I join you in that please join me in
the crossover I mean that is just
ridiculous I don't have the [ __ ] I don't
have the gate to do that
that's just stupid that's freakish this
is this is manly that is manly and you
can't even do this one that crunches
your balls you gotta do that one oh I'm
not but this is the old like uh late
night talk show yeah they always do this
yeah but they go lower because they work
lower I I'm doing this this is this is
that's a solid one that's a man's one
this is epic for me right now to be able
to do this four months ago I couldn't do
this yeah if I did this I'd have to hold
my breath and I would pull something
you know what else is interesting what
they told us what is the how they
experiment with different types of
Blends uh I compare it to like a
cocktail where you're like trying little
things some bitters in here actually
it's not working and they'll they'll
have the top part of a of a tobacco so
this goes way higher yeah right and the
top part is gets all the Sun the bottom
Parts gets all the shade and so it'll
cut the bottom part six days or six
weeks they cut the bottom leaves first
six days later they'll come back cut the
middle yeah of the plant and then
they'll come back and get the top and
they cross three different ones for
different tastes and they go like what
blend of what do we want to make this
specific type of spiciness or type of
like you know what like it's very
interesting yeah they have to figure it
out and it's all different seeds it's
it's the soil it's everything so much
goes into making a premium cigar yeah
that why do you smoke cigars it's like
why do you drink wine why do you like
whiskey here's what I'll say in a cigar
so whiskey it's like it's a taste right
um a cigar I think has multiple
components I think you've got the taste
for sure but then like does it burn
evenly like how well is it wrapped is it
a good experience overall right right so
if it burns evenly if you don't have to
light it a bunch like you always talk
about that I don't want to relight this
thing
um those all that's all leads to the
enjoyment of a cigar so that's that's
going to be definitely me spending 12
bucks
or 15 bucks exactly and the thing with
this like this cigar right now is
smoothed out smooth out it's not
affecting my tongue the way it was at
the beginning
it's uh it's it's really smooth so
here's what they said about the band the
band can actually help keep the wrapper
tight so you keep it on there holding it
all together until you get up to it and
then you can take it off yeah I heard
that too yeah I mean but some cigars
have no band
you ever go to Cigar is it like a cigar
store and they're like we have our house
blend there's no band on it people don't
know that it's cheaper if it doesn't
have a band or a box it's cheaper to
make it's still the same quality cigar
right like uh sanlatano has a small
batch one of the one of my favorite
cigars
and it has no it has no band so to make
that band that Rogan band that costs
money that costs a lot of money to make
those bands that's artwork you know
that's why like uh my father and and and
and uh Foundation they they really care
about the artwork the presentation yeah
of the cigar it doesn't matter it does
matter physically like when you watch
when you see that champagne one that
we're gonna smoke at some point at the
10 10 year it's the uh uh Universal
Perdomo Perdomo 10th anniversary
champagne yeah and it's it's an
accessible so far you can find it in a
lot of places pretty much everything and
it's good and it looks really good the
light the tan like like whatever by the
way guys leave a comment and tell us
like I'll look at them and I'll have
like my employees look at them too and
Bobby will too like if you think it's a
cigar we should be smoking that you
really like [ __ ] put it in there and
we'll add it to the [ __ ] queue We'll
add it to the queue yeah absolutely
we have a Q
of cigars
just don't make if it's a [ __ ] to God
we're not smoking you wanna take a walk
through there and keep smoking yeah
let's go that'll be fun leave that here
let's walk down aisles and keep talking
yeah we need a topic real quick as we
walk through this summer time
well yeah summertime that's what we're
talking about yeah I mean these plants
are going to be gone these plants are
going to be gone all this whole field is
gonna yeah Nick was trying to get us
down here for a long time yeah he's
trying to get us down here for a while
I'm glad we finally made it yeah he was
like guys if you wait too long they'll
all be [ __ ] dead yeah Harvest Time
this is actually the last
patch of tobacco here I didn't know that
it took three years after you picked
this [ __ ] until until you could smoke it
it takes two to three years maybe
sometimes
it depends
you know but uh
yeah I mean
look at how beautiful this is this is
really cool
yeah you know what everybody said during
the pandemic like I want to be a father
I could be a farmer and what they meant
by that is all these Millennials did it
and these gen Z years and these [ __ ]
uh Rich whites yeah what they meant was
I want to live in a farm while slaves
took care of it
oh I don't want to bash it a [ __ ]
yeah nobody really people own Farms they
work hard but not as hard as the workers
over there no benefits no all they get
is a [ __ ] fake green card in Return
yeah there's no it's not like Google
where you go to the cafeteria and
everything's free yeah pinball all you
can play Pinball yeah they have couscous
[ __ ] Greek yogurt I mean we saw them
taking their lunch break
like on a [ __ ] bale of hay yeah
yeah just farm work I mean this is
really cool to see how it's all made it
is it's beautiful
I mean you can't get you can't get more
peaceful than this yeah half of me
though think about this if you could
work on a farm yeah if you could just
call it quick but you can make money
yeah and you could work on a farm it
would be I mean there's nothing like
manual labor there's nothing like
getting up early working and there's not
you know what's the best to me feeling
physically tired at the end of the day
being worn out from hard work worn out
instead of being worn out for being on
on your phone for eight straight hours
you're like ah yeah like trash the gig
get back to your hotel room you're just
like oh thank God it's all over the show
went well people showed up it's all over
I can go home now but when you work it
when you work your ass off all day yeah
you go in around five o'clock you have
dinner you all wiped there's nothing
there's no better sleep no better sleep
you go to bed there's nothing you better
keep your eyes open you're just out I
was worried about [ __ ] how many
people liked your stupid video so I love
kids when they can just every they go
till there's zero left in them and
they're just out you can carry them
yeah that was great up in the tiny house
of summer as Max was in Camp all day
yeah like it was it wasn't camp like
City camp where they're in a [ __ ]
Park yeah and you know they're just
[ __ ] doing stupid [ __ ] he was
if you wet the cigar I'll fight you
there I'll tackle you
he was uh he was hiking
archery
camping that is very good he came home
at night dude out really wiped
which is gone
that's great yeah to be that one out can
I grab one of these off there what do
you mean no you don't think so what do
you mean you're gonna take one yeah
let's show it to the camera
I mean there seems like a billion
yeah but I mean you I feel like he'd say
yes
I mean look I get nervous you're you're
that guy
so I'm gonna leave it up to you I think
he'd be fine with it stop right here
okay
do you guys think he should rip a stock
off of this
but I mean keep in mind how many stocks
there are and how many [ __ ] each
stock on each [ __ ] plant what if that
kills that plant
what if that kills that plant no because
he showed us that it doesn't I'm gonna
do one off the bottom
[ __ ] I'll do one off the top I'll do it
off the top now okay oh my God why would
you do that this is what's going to be
the wrapper of your cigar so none of
this goes in the inside you're saying no
I I think it some of it does it depends
on these plants though like each field
is different right so it depends like
there's the bottom that's the song it's
hot out here that's the top
can you imagine being a king in like the
[ __ ] Egypt era where some guy's job
and it was a good job yeah you could be
building pyramids or you could be the
waiver guy yeah he fanned you off and
then gave you a massage and then [ __ ]
sucked your balls do you think it's
right do you think you could take that
fan home to your family at night like
it's your fan for the king or do you
have to leave it at work you have to
leave it at work you can't take a fan
home no but you can bring it back the
next day you're the fan guy what if they
catch you Fanning your father off after
a hard day of being a Slave at the
pyramid I'm saying I'd be one of the
best slave owners I would go fan your
father off do your job right if you
don't I'm gonna hang you he's not a good
slave owner they'll take advantage of
you if you're right you're gonna be hard
you can't be a [ __ ] a laxidasical
nice slave owner either you're a slave
owner or you're not what are you gonna
be the [ __ ] head on the stake every
night
[Music]
does what he's told gets the job done
but I get the nails in nice like I don't
hurt like I know how to put the nails in
your feet and your hands where it hurts
the left the least you're like hey sorry
about this yeah they'd be like hey can I
get Bobby to do my crucifixion yeah
because he he knows how to do it you
know what I mean yeah
this is [ __ ] cool
well
we're gonna wrap this we gotta get back
to New York we're gonna get back we got
shows I gotta show if you're lucky
enough to get on the Joe Rogan podcast
it's called The Joe working experience
Joe you're about to get this that orange
fear bump that two Comics two cigars
bump everybody check out his podcast
it's on Spotify now one day he'll get to
iTunes but right now he's just on
Spotify and uh you can get yourself one
of these and I'd say ask Joe can I take
one of these to go and actually that'll
bring us to the final segment of our
podcast we can walk forward yep
um uh DeRosa had a good idea he says you
call it something this section the the
the boxing or the I forget what he said
they had a title for it the the rundown
of what you should get so as you know if
you've seen this podcast before we do
would you like to get one of these would
you get no more of these ever I don't
like it we don't even know if we're in
the shot right now we're in the shot
okay we're not you can hear us yeah
um that's a great point the end of the
podcast like we said it can be any two
Comics it doesn't have to be us but it
is us it's a good moment to say this any
two comics
smoke a cigar at least one camera angle
try to get two or three yeah
um clap before you do it so we can match
up the sound or whatever and just send
it in we'll put it up on two common
subscribers it doesn't have to be us in
most of the time hopefully will not be
one of us hopefully but I like doing it
yeah yeah we'll still do plenty yeah
we'll do the we'll do the good ones you
might be like I hate Ari the re episode
it's great yeah it'll be plenty to skip
for you if you're a Cigar Company we'll
do those yeah we'll do those yeah we'll
do the importance
yes yeah it's not gonna be sagalo and
feedy
those down in Cuba but yeah you have to
be a comic though you can't you can't be
in Chicago yeah John Mayer's not doing
this he's not allowed to do it
um
so it comes to the time where we have to
say would you buy no more of these would
you buy another one if you happen to see
it at a store zero one five five meaning
like I'm gonna get a few of these so if
a friend comes over I'll have one ready
for them and I'll have one for myself
just so I have or a box a box
and I think we both know the answer to
this one I think everybody knows the
answer to this
but the sad part about the answer to
this is what you can't get it
we're the only ones
that can buy the Box the box you can get
a very very similar blend the Tabernacle
and this is also he said hard to find
hard to find but yes we would I would do
a box this is definitely they're so good
I got a box and now we got another box
can I make a suggestion yeah maybe
Nicaragua I know made here I think we we
do this you ready yeah to one of you
lucky fans out there
I don't agree with this before he says
it I want to hear it before he says it
go ahead but you already don't agree
with it I think I know where you're
going and no I don't agree with it but
go ahead
why
why one of you lucky fans out there
one of you like randomly
you leave a comment
you subscribe
you like
you tell us why you should have one of
these one of them one one fan one cigar
you gotta give them two
what we'll give them one of those in one
of those no you gotta have him be able
to smoke with a friend
of this not podcast this web series yes
is that you can smoke along with us this
is you're right you're right you're
right so he's got to have one to smoke
with a friend this is why we do this
together
I thought you were gonna say give him a
box I'm like [ __ ] that [ __ ] that guy
[ __ ] any of these [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're animals they're animals I want
to give you a box you're out of your
mind we'll give them two we'll give them
two I'll send you one
we'll send you to we'll pick randomly in
the comments we won't do it we'll have a
slave do it tell us why you deserve two
rogans two rogans
and that's how you get it from
Foundation cigars foundations the
greatest cigar that you cannot find for
sure I'd buy a box I would definitely
buy I would smoke these every day yeah I
mean it's [ __ ] beautiful you know
what advice you gave me when I got my
humidor you're like I'm like I'm trying
to fit it all into 300 count
what was the advice
I'm sorry I'm sorry
I apologize you know I think about it
already I know listen I'm kidding you're
one of the funniest but people I know
I'm a Saturday
what does it taste like seaweed chips
would you buy a box of that buy a box of
that an unboxing we had seaweed chips
you don't like them they're [ __ ]
gross
um
um yeah all right tell us why you
deserve it and we'll send you to that
seems fair that seems fair that's a nice
giveaway give a little back to the
community support it I mean the the
show's getting they love it I love it
tell some friends about it I don't know
um so all right let's get back to New
York get back to every show we're gonna
get back there we got some actually
we'll have some stuff we're putting up
with this so we hope you enjoyed the
show oh yeah when we well it'll be our
there already all that stuff was filmed
here at the uh that you saw in the lands
it was filmed here at the uh the
foundation cigars Farm yeah in
Connecticut in Connecticut United States
the Connecticut Leaf it was a big thing
and then it just died out and this guy
Nick was like no no no you traveled all
the world it's a cool guy and the end is
uh Jeffrey Jeffrey yeah these are his
Farms yeah so Nick works with Jeff with
these Farms this is the this is their
crop tobacco in America it's cool to see
where was from it really does yeah we'll
see you guys on the next episode two
common two cigars look in the bottom
we'll see we'll show you what uh we're
smoking next time so you can go out and
get ready for it and uh and uh until
next time I love you I love you too
Cheers Cheers thanks Joe thanks for
being so famous
Hey Joe no thank you so thanks for
[ __ ] losing all your anonymity and
being unable to go outside without
getting bothered for this moment I
appreciate it thanks for all your hard
work and determination
if there's anything I could ask for you
was just have a tailor make your
coattails a little longer so that we
could all grab a grab a hold of it hold
on tight
I'll see you next time
well I knew that blend would probably
suit him toad
pictures